4日
あああああああこんにちははじめ社長です
いやー3日ぶりに出たらはい時の皆さん元気にお過ごしでしょうか
私今年の目標の一つそして版を大善しようっていう心持ちがあるんですけど
フェズ歯を健康にキレイに保ちたいというわけで実は2019年に入ってから毎週です
ね歯医者に通っておりますちょっと忙しい
んですけど忙しいながら委員長さんとお話ししてこうなんとか時間を見つけてお互いの
都合のいいタイミングでなんとか歯医者に行って治療を進めているんですけども今日は
ちょっと私の歯についてお話ししようと思いますな人にはですね色んなコンプレックス
があるんですけども私のイヴァンところの一番のコンプレックスで実は
花んですできれば派はねいいってしたくなくてねなるべくこのなんか上の唇をこう
伸ばしてたら伸ばせたら気付いたら口バスみたいな唇になってしまった雪あるんです
けど犯人ねあんまり自信がないんですよあのまあ
うわぁやだなーでも今ば x ってね
さらけ出したら意外となんとかなるもんだと思うので撮ってますけれども行きますよ
ちょう嫌だけど
いきますねん
はい終了終了終了終了です今お気づきになった人いらっしゃったでしょうか前までは
全然そんなことなかったんですけどもいつからかな
去年ぐらいからかわかんないんですけど実はですねこことここどここの波だね
黒くなってきてるんですようっかり足のここどこだったらでね色の白さが違うんです
けどこっちが製造です2のするで国庫の日本かなぁここかね
第が黒いんですよ
[音楽]
クロスギンコのか月の音付近が黒いんですよねあの僕はですねー
結構気にしてますってこう見えて立って版黒いのやばくねぇ
数
なんかこうしてるとわからないですよ結構上のほうなんでニコッと笑うと猫の黒いのが
嫌なんですよ
ずっと気になってたんですよ僕この黒いのはなんなのか別に何かそんな歯が汚いわけで
もないし黒くなる原因が分からなくて来はいっていうのもなんか人にも言えなかった
スレ汚れとかでもないしかといって黒くなってるんですよこれなんだろうねって人にも
なくはずですけど言えなくてあ困ってたんですけども毎週歯医者に通うことによって
戦前にやっとのここで打ち明けて来相談すること
あってきて
そう
僕の前バー片方だけ黒くなってるんです
なんでキャディ聞いたところ議員が分かりまして本当に汚れとか汚いとか
虫歯とかじゃなくてちゃんとした別の理由がありました
今日はそのお話をさせていただきましょうエコわかるか見てる人気付いた人いったか
なぁこれだけね笑わないように気をつけてたんですけどはラウドネハが黒いんですよね
ここだけ
うわぁヤダー自分やだやだったらやだやだいやマジで結構コンプ
x 皆さんにもうコンプレックスあると思うんですけど僕は母のこのくらいココです皆
さん話が逸れましたね
では説明させていただきましょう時はさかのぼり肇社長が高校3年生の頃でした肇社長
は大学受験が終わり
黒公立大学静岡大学の合格多いでテーション max 長調しノリノリで
春休みを満喫していましたがマミーが肇社長にこんな相談をしました
始めあんた静岡言ったら色々わからないと思うから今のうちにず本の歯医者でねハト科
の治療しておきな体操言われた僕は確かにいいと思ってよく行っていた地元の歯医者に
行きました
会社に行って歯医者の先生がまず
こう言っていましたん枝くーん
そうだね君のハワーオ前歯が虫歯だねぇ
うそこから高校3年生春休み最後の修行はじめ社長の虫歯治療生活が始まりました
虫歯も痛いですが治療も痛いまっせえよ口
神経を抜くこの動作が肇社長の心身を苦しめ
高校3年生の初め社長はメンタルが非常に良く
恋愛に達しもう歯医者に行きたくねえその肝臓が
彼の農園の99%を占めたとき一つの答えにたどり着きました
バックレたまま静岡引っ越しすれば逃げ切れるんじゃねぇ
そう考えた肇社長は
歯医者に行くとバック0吹き碑が建ちそのまま
虫歯の治療途中である前歯を折ったまま静岡に引っ越すし大学生活を送りましたとさ
ちゃんちゃん
それから4年後
だんだん
治療途中の歯がー
黒くなっているということに
[音楽]
はいという流れでございますあの簡単に言えば敗者脱走したせいで歯が黒くなっている
という事ですそ
あのまあマジバの治療は完成してて神経を抜くんですよね虫歯ってね真剣抜いた歯って
何が起きるかというと栄養とかがなんか行かなくなってその白い歯がだんだん黒くなっ
ていくんだってなんかもろくなっている栄養が行かなかったりしてその色あせっていう
のは
もうホワイトニングとこんな音ないしどうしようもなく黒くなってください来て何でも
com ショアの釣りはできてるんですけども神経がなくて栄養がいかなくて
この年を重ねるごとにだんだんかの黒ずんできたっていう話らしいですで今行ってる歯
医者の院長さんに聞いたんですけども
あーこれそうだね多分前入ってなかったって言われて言ってました
ましたこれダメね前の歯医者さんの人情さんが前歯を愛のまま残したくてこのままで
知っておいたのかもしれないねみたいなどうすれば黒くならないかというとこれもとっ
て新しい葉にすれば黒くならないんですけど今の院長さん皆さんの前の歯医者さんで
木の葉を残してあげたいからモノマネしておいたんじゃないかなっていう考察をしてた
んですけど全然違います新しい針の
ある前に脱走しました
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ
ないというわけでですね今何か別の歯の治療してるんですけども
多分使えずに9黒く黒ずんでる幅あの白い歯になっていると思います全然は汚れるわけ
じゃないかね純正に母の進化なくてあんなん黒ずんできてるだけなんで
汚いとかそういうわけじゃないですけどやっぱ黒ずみっていうのはあんまり綺麗なもん
じゃないよねっていう話ですまあはラバンない
ければ見えないんで普通なんですけど我々はやっぱりねこれ本ドネアの動画で気づいた
人いたら聞きたいんですを始めちゃうのは前歯が黒くなっている犬が気づいていたら
是非コメント欄で書いてください気付いている人がいなかったら僕はただいま自爆し
てるだけなんて早く治して